for a few weeks between the wet and dry  seasons this seemingly ordinary looking  river bursts to life with colour  [Music]  carno cristales is located in meta  colombia  when the conditions are just right an  endemic aquatic plant species that lives  in the riverbed blooms creating a  brilliant show of red color often with  hints of yellow orange green and blue  because of this locals refer to the  river as the liquid rainbow or the river  of five colours  before 2009 meccano cristales was closed  off to the public due to guerrilla  activity in the surrounding region  today the river can be reached by  horseback or by foot and is accessible  under the guidance of local tour guides  although this phenomenon only happens  for a short period of time each year  this living rainbow leaves a lasting  impression  [Music]  you